Logan ranks among the very best superhero
movies of all time and although director James
Mangold said that he got everything he wanted
in the final cut of the movie, there are still
some fascinating scenes that didn't make it
into the film.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and with the Blu-ray of Logan out now, I'm
going to break down all the official deleted
scenes and discuss some easter eggs and details
we never got to see in the theatrical release.
Quick spoiler warning: if you haven't seen
Logan yet, there will be spoilers for the
movie.
If you want to avoid them, tap up here for
my spoiler-free review and come back after
you've seen the film!
There are a couple of cut scenes involving
the mutant children that Logan and Laura meet
at Eden.
First up is a scene with Bobby, a young mutant
with electrical powers, who has an action
figure of Sabretooth and another of Wolverine.
Bobby asks Logan if Sabretooth was ever real.
Logan explains to Bobby that some of it was
true and that Sabretooth was real and that
both he and Victor were developed as part
of a weapons program just like Bobby was.
The scene is a nod back to X-Men Origins:
Wolverine where we saw Wolverine and Sabretooth's
early history as [half-]brothers.
The scene also has a bit of hidden meaning
as we know from Bobby's file that the DNA
source for his electrical powers comes from
Christopher Bradley, aka Bolt, and it was
Sabretooth who killed Chris Bradley in Origins:
Wolverine.
There's also a tender moment when Bobby tries
to convince Logan that he's doing good in
the world now despite any bad things he might
have done in the past and I feel that this
deleted moment would have made the scene later
when Bobby is holding the Wolverine action
figure at Logan's funeral even more poignant.
The Sabretooth action figure is also interesting
because, during Logan's development, Liev
Schreiber was approached to return one final
time as Sabretooth in a potential storyline
where Logan found his brother Victor in charge
of a major casino.
Many fans would have loved to have seen the
pair reunited as their performances in X-Men
Origins: Wolverine are one of the few bright
spots in what is often considered one of the
worst X-Men movies to date.
Sadly, scheduling conflicts and the way the
story developed mean that his mention in a
deleted scene is the best nod we got to Sabretooth
in Logan.
Now, there's a pretty dark deleted scene involving
one of the other mutant kids who director
James Mangold has called the "Puppet Master".
This child uses his powers of mental manipulation
to stop a Reaver who's chasing him by making
him turn on and shoot his fellow Reavers.
And in an even darker twist, the kid then
makes that same Reaver turn the gun on himself.
After Caliban blew himself up, there was a
deleted extended death scene where, although
badly injured, he managed to get out of the
truck and crawl towards Logan.
In that scene, Logan and Laura lock eyes with
Caliban before he's finally overcome by his
injuries and they walk away.
I think this extended scene was probably better
left out as it was fairly clear in the film
that Caliban wasn't going to survive after
dropping a couple of grenades near himself.
And if the scene had been in the film, it
would have no doubt seemed odd or even somewhat
callous that Logan took Charles but not Caliban
with them, however, this cut scene does give
a little closure to Caliban's story and maybe
highlights that his sacrifice wasn't in vain
and was acknowledged by both Logan and Laura.
Actor Richard E. Grant felt rather underused
in Logan, however, there's a little extra
deleted scene with Dr Rice where Pierce shows
him that's he uncovered some coordinates to
a location in the Badlands, a reservation
on the border that's also in an X-Men comic.
We then discover that Rice is holding hostage
a nurse who worked at Alkali Transigen and
demanding she explain the meaning of the comic
book and the coordinates.
Although not totally necessary, the scene
does give a touch more screen time to Richard
E. Grant and fills in a likely explanation
for how Pierce and Rice knew where to find
Laura and the other refugee mutant children.
A deleted scene which didn't really affect
the final film sees Logan, Laura and Charles
pulled over by a police officer for speeding
after leaving the casino at Oklahoma City.
For this moment, director James Mangold was
going for the feel of the road movie Little
Miss Sunshine where the family gets pulled
over by a cop on their journey to a beauty
pageant.
Although this scene is a little humorous and
includes Laura acknowledging Logan as her
father, the scene was nearly two minutes long
and it's easy to see why it got cut.
The Munson family dinner scene also had a
much darker alternative version.
In the alternate, partly improvised, scene,
Kathryn asks Logan if he was ever married,
and Charles takes over the conversation saying
that Logan was married one time, except that
now she's dead because Logan killed her.
This revelation by Charles is, obviously,
pretty awkward for Logan, and although Mangold
has said that he wanted the dinner scene to
provide some levity, this version actually
feels a bit too dark given everything that's
about to happen at the Munson family home.
And although according to Mangold, Logan stands
alone as an X-Men film and he tried to avoid
getting tied down connecting it to the wider
X-Men movie universe, this scene might still
have been confusing because the X-Men timeline
after Days of Future Past appeared to invalidate
the first three X-Men movies including Wolverine's
killing of Jean Grey in The Last Stand.
So, what do you think about the deleted scenes
and where there any you think should have
been in the movie?
And which X-Men movie or TV series are you
most looking forward to next?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
And if you enjoyed this video, don't forgot
to give it a thumbs-up and you can also check
out more Logan deleted scenes and concept
art in this video right here and I'll also
have new Wonder Woman videos coming up this
week, so make sure you subscribe!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.